[Musica]
ho visto la circonferenza della terra
l'orizzonte sopra la superficie ha un
colore blu meraviglioso che diventa
sempre più intenso passando tonalità di
rosso per poi diventare oscurità
assoluta con queste parole yuri gagarin
descriveva la sua visione della terra
nell'aprile del 1961 in quel preso conto
del primo uomo dello spazio viene
ripetuto moltissime volte il verbo ho
visto perché è la visione che cambia la
percezione e per la prima volta un uomo
aveva potuto percepire la terra nella
sua interezza
era una rappresentazione che andava al
di là dell'immaginazione finalmente era
vera
gli oceani e continenti tutte le foreste
i deserti tutto poteva essere racchiuso
in uno sguardo ma il percorso per
arrivare a quella consapevolezza come
specie umana è durato migliaia di anni
ed è tutto sommato un battito di ciglia
se lo confrontiamo con quella che la
storia del sistema solare cominciata ben
4,5 miliardi di anni fa
noi siamo apparsi come specie solo
200.000 anni fa nelle savane africane
all'inizio ci siamo rifugiati nelle
caverne per proteggerci dal mondo
esterno ma ci siamo anche subito
scoperti esploratori quindi abbiamo
cominciato un percorso abbiamo macinato
chilometri migliaia di chilometri
generazione dopo generazione alla
ricerca di nuovi luoghi dove vivere
nuovi territori da includere nella
nostra geografia di esseri umani circa
40.000 anni fa avevamo percorso
l'eurasia e l'australia 15 mila anni fa
attraversavamo i continenti americani
verso la patagonia è solo mille anni fa
abbiamo raggiunto le isole più remote
degli oceani ma se andiamo a vedere
quello che abbiamo compiuto nell'ultimo
secolo è assolutamente straordinario
perché siamo usciti dalla nostra comfort
zone e siamo riusciti a scalare per
esempio le montagne più alte come lei
nel 1953 per poi sviluppare la
tecnologia necessaria per scendere negli
abissi marini come la fossa delle
marianne
e da qui nel 1959 siamo perfino riusciti
a vedere a un certo punto invisibile
quando la sonda russa luna 3 ci ha
mandato questa immagine
l'immagine del lato nascosto del dark
side della luna negli ultimi poi 20 anni
siamo riusciti a togliere il velo del
mistero a luoghi veramente lontanissimi
pensiamo solo ai satelliti di giove e di
saturno ceres per esempio a mercurio ea
luoghi anche particolarissimi che non
avremmo mai pensato di poter neppure
vedere da così vicino come una cometa la
cometa 67p della missione rosetta
esplorata dall'agenzia spaziale europea
ma quando guardiamo questi oggetti
lontani questi mondi lontani e quello
che riusciamo a vedere solo la
superficie non riusciamo ad andare oltre
e anche quando ci rivolgiamo indietro
verso la terra la nostra conoscenza si
limita a un sottilissimo spessore
esterno che il luogo dove noi viviamo
come esseri umani negli ultimi due
decenni ci stiamo accorgendo che però la
frontiera dell'esplorazione non è solo
nella profondità dello spazio ma
potrebbe essere anche qui ad esempio ci
sono sotto i nostri piedi gli speleologi
in giro per il mondo hanno esplorato
circa 40.000 km di caverne abissi
caverne sistemi anche molto molto grandi
e questi 40 mila chilometri non sono
altro che una minima parte di quello che
sicuramente esiste ma è ancora
sconosciuto e abbiamo portato la luce e
luoghi che sfidano l'immaginazione dei
romanzi di jules verne come la grotta
dei cristalli giganti di naica esplorata
da un team italiano la venta un luogo
del genere che sembra extraterrestre in
realtà è qui e qui sul nostro pianeta e
potrebbero essercene migliaia come
questo giusto qualche chilometro qui
sotto i nostri piedi
ma se ci siamo resi conto adesso che la
frontiera dell'esplorazione potrebbe
essere sotto la superficie del pianeta
terra cosa potremmo trovare se andassimo
a vedere oltre
nel sottosuolo
di altri pianeti nel 2007 un geologo
americano della nasa glen caching
osservando delle immagini satellitari
che arrivavano da marte dalla sonda mars
odyssey individua alcuni buchi sulla
superficie di dei vulcani marziani
inizialmente sono sette sono dei buchi
neri sono sette le chiama le sette
sorelle seven sisters e guardandoli
anche con immagini satellitari e più
alta risoluzione non si riesce proprio a
vederne il fondo possiamo solo arrivare
a vedere il limite dell'ombra che in
questo caso arriva a circa 350 metri di
profondità oltre il bordo oltre quel
quel limite non possiamo vedere quindi
potrebbe essere profondo centinaia anche
migliaia di metri
non esiste attualmente nessuna sonda
satellite in orbita che ci permetta di
vedere oltre la superficie capire che
tipologia di grotte potrebbe esistere lì
sotto
e quindi ci sono molte domande che si
stanno facendo gli scienziati due anni
dopo nel 2009 un altro scienziato
giudici haruyama giapponese osservando
le immagini del satellite lunar
reconnaissance orbiter
scopri che anche sulla luna ci sono dei
posti nei pozzi profondi
in particolare ne individua due il primo
a quello di marius hills e poi dei mari
e tranquillità tease sono profondi circa
50 100 metri ma la cosa interessante qui
guardandoli da un'angolazione magari più
bassa sull'orizzonte
si vede che al di sotto si aprono delle
caverne delle caverne profonde che non
sappiamo quanto possono continuare e
quindi veramente si apre una nuova
frontiera anche scientifica che che tipo
di grotte potrebbero esistere la sotto
ci sono moltissime domande quando noi ci
siamo messi a studiare queste strutture
è un gruppo di ricercatori
dell'università di bologna in vista di
padova
l'unico indizio che avevamo era che
queste questi buchi questi posti si
aprono nei territori vulcanici della
luna di marte come per esempio il
vulcano del monte olympus il più alto
del sistema solare 23 chilometri di
altezza oppure ne marian
della luna che sono quelle macchie scure
che noi vediamo anche a occhio nudo che
se non sono altro che dei grandi bacini
riempiti dalle ave basaltiche e quindi
per capire per trovare delle risposte
alle domande scientifiche che avevamo
siamo andati esplorare e studiare le
grotte vulcaniche della terra i
cosiddetti tubi la dc i tubi da vinci si
formano attraverso un flusso di magma
durante un'eruzione il flusso sui
superficiale è esposto diciamo
all'atmosfera quindi si raffredda forma
una crosta forma quindi una volta e
all'interno invece in questo fiume di
lava continua a scorrere a scavare
creare un tunnel che può essere lungo
anche le decine di chilometri ce ne sono
un po in tutti i vulcani terrestri anche
qui sull'etna per esempio ci sono sono
in giappone alle hawaii in islanda ma
c'è un luogo in particolare che l'isola
di lanzarote dove esiste un tubo lavico
veramente norme si chiama il tubo della
corona nove chilometri di sviluppo e
anche qui questo tubo si apre verso la
superficie con dei crolli che i geologi
chiamano skylight il lucernaio molto
simili del tutto analoghi a quello che
vediamo sulla luna e su marte per
riuscire a capire se veramente siamo di
fronte alle stesse tipo di strutture
abbiamo realizzato un rilievo laser
scanner ad altissima risoluzione di
questo di questo tubo lavico e grazie a
questo modello tridimensionale abbiamo
potuto misurare i volumi interni capire
come si sviluppa il tubo al di sotto
della superficie e visualizzarlo
e quindi scalarlo e vedere il confronto
per esempio quella luna e con marte
capire anche che tipo di flussi di lava
lo hanno attraversato e tutte queste
informazioni sono utili per poi
estrapolare dei modelli matematici che
ci possono dire sostanzialmente che cosa
c'è lì sotto sotto la luna è sotto marte
cos'è dive diverso rispetto per esempio
alla alla terra la prima cosa che balza
all'occhio è che vedete in questa
immagine è che c'è una enorme differenza
di scala sopra abbiamo un'immagine
satellitare del tubo della corona e la
slavezza degli skylight dei lucernai di
circa alcune decine di metri al massimo
trenta metri mentre se andiamo su marte
una situazione analoga ecco che le
dimensioni aumentano si parla di un
ordine di grandezza di più circa 100
anche 200 300 metri ma la situazione
diventa ancora più impressionante
immaginate già un astronauta un
astronauta speleologo che entra in un
tubo lavico marziano si troverebbe di
fronte a un tunnel di questo tipo enorme
la più grande struttura di grande di
qualsiasi struttura che noi esseri umani
abbiamo mai potuto costruire qua sulla
terra ma se andasse sulla luna che cosa
troverebbe sulla luna abbiamo visto che
la situazione aumenta ancora di più
parliamo di due ordini di grandezza
quindi dei tunnel che arrivano oltre un
chilometro di ampiezza
ciò significa che tutto il centro di
torino potrebbe essere contenuto
facilmente in uno di questi condotti e
la puglia della mole antonelliana non
riuscirebbe neppure ad avvicinarsi a
soffitto e abbiamo calcolato che uno di
questi tunnel potrebbe avere un volume
di circa un miliardo di metri cubi
potrebbe contenere al suo interno un
1400 volte la basilica di san pietro
e questo è possibile sulla luna perché
abbiamo un pianeta più piccolo che una
gravità minore circa un sesto di quella
terrestre e quindi una volta così
gigantesca mentre qui sulla terra
crollerebbe non potrebbe essere mai
stabile sulla luna invece rimane stabile
anche per miliardi di anni
forse un giorno non sommato non lontano
riusciremo a vedere all'interno di
queste grotte e l'agenzia spaziale si
stanno preparando per questo per questa
sfida sviluppando tecnologie e anche
l'agenzia spaziale europea e su questa
strada ma per ora ci vorrebbe uno
speleologo ma non possiamo mandarcelo e
quindi dobbiamo accontentarci dei
modelli matematici modelli matematici
sappiamo che potrebbero non essere
corretti potrebbero magari essere
leggermente diversi da quello che è la
realtà ma quello che è certo che lì
sotto esiste un mondo sconosciuto che
potenzialmente enorme abbiamo visto come
la nasa è riuscito a far atterrare su
marte il rover passivi runs
quel drover quel robot a un preciso
precisa missione trovare la vita le
tracce della vita ma sappiamo anche che
la vita attualmente sulla superficie di
marte non è possibile perché la
radiazione cosmica è troppo forte ma
potremmo trovare delle condizioni
completamente diverse all'interno di una
grotta la volta ci protegge dalle
radiazioni dalla pioggia di
micrometeoriti perfino al temperature
potrebbero essere molto più simili a
quelle che abbiamo qui sulla terra
quindi forse un giorno dovremo andare a
cercare la vita lì sotto se vogliamo
trovare una vita che ancora è attiva e
non è solo del passato
allo stesso modo noi esseri umani
potremo utilizzare quelle caverne per
proteggerci dalle radiazioni per
l'ambiente esterno nei nostri viaggi
interplanetari proprio come abbiamo
fatto all'inizio del nostro percorso
come specie umana circa 200.000 anni fa
nelle savane africane
ma tutto questo evidentemente apre una
nuova prospettiva per l'esplorazione
dello spazio
dobbiamo però imparare a guardare oltre
la superficie perché quello che
troveremo è sicuramente molto al di là
della nostra immaginazione
grazie
[Applauso]